[Music]
we start off on this incredibly long
runway and then this antelope airplane
comes into land and so on the on the the
front of it you sort of said oh no how
are we gonna do that for real but then
Justin comes along he says well we can't
get a real plane but we can't build most
of a real plane so you know he'll go to
whatever lengths he can to shoot stuff
in camera to get stuff for real
so we huge a huge set piece for the
antelope
seventy-five feet long and seventy feet
wide and it was the sort of main section
of the fuselage where the wheels and the
undercarriage meet the ground obviously
was the plane is in the air has to be
digital and there's no way to run cars
fast enough to get alongside an airplane
or to film with it safely so and then
they had another set piece which formed
the ramp at the back of the plane
because a lot of the action revolved
around cars going in and out so justin
was was adamant that that had to happen
for real and it had to be done at speed
on the runway in the real location and
then the last set piece that they built
was for the destruction but there were a
few different set pieces for that but
again it was all addressed
it wasn't picture ready but it was a
one-to-one scale partial build of the
centre of the fuselage and the wings and
engines and also the nose of the plane
and then our special effects supervisor
Joss Williams was able to basically run
that down the runway set on fire trigger
explosions and actually half the cause
Ian's camera running in front of it we
spent a long time looking at the
dynamics of the construction of the
fuser arch the way that the grip
structures were clad with this fairly
lightweight metal
and that has the plane impacted the rips
compressed and the plane basically
started to shrug its metal surface often
you get this little sort of ripple
running back through food plane the
cameraman can go and react to something
the DFP can go up and exposed for the
fire correctly at his stunt drivers that
are in the cars are sort of driving for
their lives because they're basically
got a the 40-ton burning plane rig chase
even to found the runway and all that
stuff adds to the to the realism I think
[Music]